depuis quelques jours les chiffres covit
semble remonter et certains craignent
une sixième vague ce sera à cause d'un
variant du variant au micron bea points
dont on dirait une orientation
est ce que c'est c'est vrai cette
affaire ça on peut avoir une sixième
bague parce que même même livier vers
ans a alerté a dit attention achtung
achtung est ce qu'on peut avoir les
contaminations qui remonte donc faire
une sixième vague de contaminations oui
c'est un peu la direction que ça prend
c'est à dire que ça prend en angleterre
qui a toujours un petit peu d'avancé est
en train de le suivre est-ce que c'est
grave non parce qu'aujourd'hui les virus
qui circule avec la vaccination et
l'immunité naturelle qu'on a acquis
c'est l'équivalent de la grippe c'est ce
que disent les anglais donc s'il faut
faire un branle bas de combat à chaque
fois qu'il ya une vague de grippe donc
je pense qu'on sur-réagi un petit peu
mais j'espère et je vais appeler
l'impression que c'est la direction
comprend qu'on va rester ce soit
stratégie de revenir dans un an un mode
de vie normale et ne plus être dans la
conception fini les confinements les
vallées les trucs voilà les bars fermés
ont fermé il couvre feu les couvreurs je
pense que les confinements les
couvre-feux oui je pense que finisar
pense que ça s'est terminé après les
rappels vaccinaux pour une partie de la
population ne peut pas s'engager là
dessus parce qu'on a encore plein
d'incertitudes sur la durée de cette
immunité d'accord oui est ce qu'on peut
dire aujourd'hui que dès le début
c'était une grosse grippe le commis dans
ou alors d'accord le seul job au début
mais il ya des courses est intéressant
qui sont montrés au début on était
quasiment à 20 fois la grippe en taux de
mortalité donc ça n'a rien à voir mais
là effectivement depuis l'arrivée de
micros on était sur une bible qu'est ce
qu'on a sur réagi et cette vague au
micro oui très probablement donc
maintenant est vraiment passé sur autre
chose et on est plutôt quelque chose de
l'ordre de la grippe effectivement mais
ce n'est pas brillant giraldi non mais
d'un côté vous dites y'a les alarmistes
de l'autre côté les rassure east d'un
côté il ya ceux qui ont fait 0 qu'ovide
et l'autre et d'autres qui ont dit non
mais finalement c'est rien on l'est on
laisse faire en fait quel est le pays
qui a fait vraiment beaucoup mieux que
nous est-ce qu il ya un pays qui a fait
vraiment beaucoup mieux que l'on
finalement bah moi quand vous parlez que
des gens qui voyagent beaucoup à
l'international
ils vous disent qu'il ya peu de pays qui
ont été aussi stricte que la france
c'est à dire que les confinements tel
que nous l'a connue ou deviez signer un
papier pour aller à plus de 500 mètres
de votre domicile c'est quelque chose
qui n'existe nulle part ailleurs en
monte et l'autre chose c'est que la peur
du coville a été je pense l'une des plus
importantes au monde sait que l'anxiété
qu'on a transmis à la population ça a
été en france ce d'érable en france en
france et quand vous parler avec des
gens qui font du business et qui vont
par exemple en scandinavie même en
allemagne en italie et le 10 mai la
trouille du coc vide c'est quelque chose
de français c'est à dire qu'il n'y avait
pas ces tagueurs n'avait pas peur
panique dans les autres pays et je pense
que ça ça joue aussi avec sa wii mais
par exemple vous allez on scandé bonnet
la suède ça fait un an et demi que les
gens y est normalement sur anglet
regarder ça fait quasiment un an que les
gens vivent ça c'est enrageant en france
les gens sont restés ils ont été marqués
bah oui mais oui la scandinavie
l'utilisons été surtout marquée par le
premier traumatisme médias matin cette
continuité de peur comme ça en
permanence pendant deux ans la
scandinavie et écoule mai dernier est
allé de l'activé beaucoup de candidats
est-ce qu'il fallait vacciner bah bien
sûr il fallait l'accord qui met en
revanche en revanche sur la vague ou
micron est ce qu'on aura nécessairement
besoin de faire un booster chez les
moins de 60 ans la réponse est non et on
ne savait pas à l'époque cette décision
était prise potins
paraissent compliquées dans la vie
quotidienne des gens parce que beaucoup
la reçoivent des notifications comme
quoi le pass va expirer et vous devez
prendre un rendez vous pour faire un
énième rappel il faut continuer à faire
ça vous pensez qu'il faut abandonner
tout ça maintenant ça concerne à non
mais non ça concerne des défis énormes
et dijon si vous donner mon avis oui
scientifique si vous avez plus de 50 ans
allez faire votre appel si vous avez
moins de 50 ans allait le faire si vous
êtes vous voulez mettre ceinture et
bretelles mais c'est pas la chose la
plus importante du monde vous aurez sans
doute d'autres problèmes plus importants
que ça dans la vie